[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning new
unemployment numbers out this morning
show a huge number of Americans are
still asking for government help the
Labor Department says another one and a
half million Americans filed for jobless
benefits last week more than 45 million
claims have been submitted since the
coronavirus crisis began three months
ago CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us Jill numbers down
slightly from last week but this is
still a very big number isn't it
it is and we were expecting that claims
would be down maybe to 1.2 or 1.3
million a still huge number but this is
just a slight improvement from the prior
week and you know although it is the
11th consecutive week where we are
seeing claims go down we are still so
high so many Americans suffering
remember back in February we saw weekly
claims in the 200,000 range we're still
at one and a half million three months
into the financial fallout from the
pandemic so this is still a really
serious situation Anthony Jo we did see
a bump in retail sales in May they were
up nearly 18% how encouraging is that
for an economic rebound well I think it
is encouraging and like the monthly jobs
numbers and even these slight
improvements in the weekly numbers we
like to take some wins here but I think
it's also important to remember the
context April was the worst month ever
on record for retail sales May was the
best month so it's great to have a
rebound but it's also really important
to note we've got a long way to go I
always like to think of it this way if
someone said hey there's a 12 foot deep
hole and you have to fill it and now a
month later we say great news it's only
10 feet deep it's still a 10 foot deep
hole that needs to be filled in that
retail sales report one item really
caught my eye clothing sales they were a
hundred eighty eight
in May but they're still down more than
63 percent from a year ago the hole is
deep and we need to fill it it's going
to take some time Jill the Fed Chairman
has warned that there's still
significant uncertainty ahead what do
you think the likelihood of another
stimula or the necessity of another
stimulus package is at this point well
Jerome Powell did testify before
Congress this week and he made it quite
clear that there are so many Americans
that are going to be hurt and some of
those are in the hardest hit sectors
tourism restaurants bars
he believes that both the Federal
Reserve and Congress are going to have
to keep those efforts up that does mean
probably a new round of stimulus or the
extension of unemployment benefits the
other thing that Powell noted is that
the pandemic has been an inequality
increase or meaning those most
vulnerable low-income Americans black
Americans Hispanics they are hurting the
most they will likely need the most
government assistance Anthony yeah
concerns about widening to divide the
economic divide in the country all right
Joe Schlesinger thank you Jill